see one thing about a father a real
father I Don't Care What ethnicity if
you say something about his kids
is personal
if you say somebody's woman
is personal if you just come on his
property or do something that you have
no business doing
it gets personal and the reason it's so
personal to me is they say it's about my
kids
you think I'm gonna let them talk about
y'all if they ain't gonna be personal
you think I'm gonna let them doubt y'all
and they ain't gonna be personal you
think I'm gonna let them snakes take
y'all and they ain't gonna get personal
you think I'm gonna let them say all the
stuff that they said and that we don't
have and we prove that we have it even
when we proved that we had it they say
it on me
therefore guess what
the first person
this person